if you think the male can sometimes be
slow consider this letters packages and
presents first sent from Jordan eight
years ago are finally arriving at their
intended destinations Jonathan Vigliotti
gives us the story a dusty mailroom in
Jericho is buzzing back to life
everything from letters to wheelchairs
thousands of mail sacks from all over
the world sifted through and sorted then
loaded on scooters like - aliens and
ferried through the winding streets of
Ramallah to their final destination
recipients like father Khalid Al and
Amman looked like they've just received
a message in a bottle and in a way
there's now old back-to-school backpack
for his daughter has survived stormy
seas for the first time in eight years
Palestinians are receiving international
mail more than 10 tons of it have been
held in Jordan since 2010 because Israel
who controls the West Bank's border
wouldn't allow it to transfer some of
them were damaged some of them have no
identified or diseased postman Ramadan
kazowie now acts as an investigator
piecing together addresses faded by time
it takes from me my critics here maybe
for two weeks I hope to which we will
finish it on Israel calls the mail
transfer a one-time gesture as it works
to implement a 2016 agreement that would
allow a direct delivery between the West
Bank and Jordan for now extra postman
have been hired to handle this backlog
in the West Bank progress like these
deliveries is a long time coming for CBS
this morning Saturday Jonathan Vigliotti
London but it must be pretty eerie to
get an 8 year old letter suddenly in the
mail